[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
put your hands together for that young
Bowl Shane Gillis
hey
[Applause]
I don't have much
because this is gay
you went to Army as a recruited football
player yeah you grew up in Pennsylvania
what an amazing
story yeah we talked about it that's
funny technically I do have a pretty
[ __ ] sick like resume yeah because I
played uh it's D1 football and then if
you join West Point if you join the Army
during uh active War you are technically
I'm a decorated veteran
that's a metal let's say I quit right
away
I quit West Point right away first month
and uh
then you know I got SNL so technically
I'm a division one football player that
is a decorated veteran and was cast on
Saturday night
and I I didn't do one of those things
but that is my resume technically
yes
I [ __ ] you yeah
yeah your punch lines have to be strong
dude just such a long build up like it
better be a good thing
a mediocre joke that we all waited 10
minutes for
that [ __ ] stinks
that was a funny joke but it just was so
long that by the end we're like yeah
no one don't talk [ __ ] dude I know
you're about to start talking [ __ ]
no and for real what is England from uh
yeah yeah good I'm glad you can't talk
[ __ ] dude
yo God's got my back on this one
hey you know when I love from my fellow
comedians when I'm doing my jokes
healing their [ __ ] beer open
I know okay my bad I went to Catholic
school and kids would [ __ ] faint we
had to go to church every week There's
No Air Conditioning it was hot as [ __ ]
yeah kids would faint not and as
Catholic so you're standing and kneeling
standing were you an altar boy no I
wasn't I got out of it all nice I got
caught in third grade drinking the wine
damn yeah third grade the priest came in
and he's like
I wish we learned more about like
European history in in school that was
what I I don't feel like we learned
anything about what the hell happened
with Europe
think about teaching a class think of
the girls in your class
you'd be like hey kids let's talk about
Archduke
just remembering a cup that collection
of words
I'm like Ferdinand duker yeah I like
that guy he's got a hell of a fastball
yeah dude I I wish there was more of
that Japan I I tried to watch a
documentary about the samurai yeah
that's fun yeah the different warring
the different warring facts the new one
yeah yeah I didn't start it yet that's
things you you should consume when you
get older and then go oh now it makes
sense back when I was young yeah you
shouldn't start that when you're young
you should learn like CPR and how to
cook
Catholic school is dog [ __ ] dude
literally I went to to this day I've
I've only gotten through like uh 30
seconds of a tutorial how to properly
save someone using CPR well they change
it they have to change it all the time
because now you don't have to ever do it
in person yeah no kissing though now you
don't have to kiss
that's the best part
because you told me you wouldn't you
wouldn't give your mom
[Laughter]
for the people who are listening who
can't see this right now there is a that
gives me I don't know Shane do you want
to set this up for the people who like
what we're looking at right now for the
people who can't see uh drunk dude
dropped his hat
and uh used I don't know used his shitty
friend to help him try I don't know I
don't want to say
[Laughter]
one arm and one leg dangling him in onto
the tracks where head first where he is
straining to reach his honestly a
hideous hat yeah and then it's such an
ugly house pulls him sideways if a train
were coming his friend would Panic try
to pull him back instead of to the side
and he would [ __ ] die what would it
take well Shane what would it take for
you today would it be tough phone would
it be tough no [ __ ] no phone absolutely
not no it'd have to be like a [ __ ]
human yeah it would have to be human it
would be a white human
I went to the cirrogon
Francis and ganu fight with Rogan so I
was front it was just me to the cage I
was sitting in front of the cage and
it's terrifying bro it's so scary
especially see those dudes get in there
you're like every and it's funny because
you could see my face the whole event so
everybody was texting me like yo relax
the whole fight I was like
[Laughter]
just a checked leg kick I was like
now but the noise is the noise is
disgusting so scary when you hear
someone get punched in the chest in the
belly it's it's disgusting when you hear
Shangri let's go stop hey no no no no no
get out you don't need this goat you're
still young dude yeah it was bad uh what
do you do in the shadows you [ __ ]
vampire
you're you're 26. so do you put a sock
on the door to let your mom know you're
jerking off or what
yes
yeah
no I was just trying to go along with
what what is it like you have ever
gotten caught masturbating at home
yes I have what was that like can you
can you describe to us what that moment
was did you turn into a bat
the room
count wacula
there we go here we go I'm fired up
it was a hurricane it was Hurricane
Barry it was crazy I gotta just paint
the picture of what it cause Tommy Tommy
Pope and I passed guests on the show
were just kind of like you know [ __ ]
and you got the guys on the couch we're
having a good time we knew Shane was
gonna come in late but we had no idea
what's happening in the outside world
and Shane walks in Dripping like like a
covered in water if he just got out of a
bath as if I was underwater like a dad
that just lost his family like truly
that upset head down and I'm just
looking oh man it's the funniest [ __ ]
image I've ever seen in my life I went
from yeah never mind
wet said Shane has got to be one of the
funniest videos it's tough man I gotta
say your hair fell right into place
though it did look nice yeah that's
because I was [ __ ] doing that when I
walked in and then I looked in the in
the Monitor and I was like oh nice
I should actually do my hair once before
you lose it next week but that's the
thing post rain hair might be the
greatest your hair could ever be
when my hair gets wet it's [ __ ]
insanely like you can just it's like
bald scalp yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like if I'm if I'm in a pool I look like
I'm like 58.
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] that sucks when it all
just cuts like it it just clumps
together and you see the top of yourself
you're like oh this is this is like a
loose leaf on the top of a hole that's
what you're here it's like a trick like
I walk like if I'm at the pool I look
like just like a fat 12 year old walking
around sure and then if I jump in and
like come out of the water it's like
Jesus
the chlorine is aging people this pool
and Chernobyl
Cherno pool I'd like to thank Ari and
his people for this beautiful weather
thank you
Ari used to host the show this is not
happening a show named after his comedy
career
[Applause]
Ari is edgy and shocking which is a
really cool thing for a 50 year old guy
to be
isn't it cool
is preposterous for kids yes crazy it's
outright I would honestly come out and
Vlog if I saw a bunch of kids playing
touch I'd come out and Yeah and say hey
start hitting the [ __ ] out of here lower
your head lower your shoulder yeah not
your head lower your shoulder then my
one friend Mike Connelly got hit puberty
he was not allowed to play anymore you
said we started secretly playing tackle
football started secretly playing
football without him and occasionally be
like hurry can I come over and be like
dude get out of here yeah no way that
was so good dude peeping out dude's
armpit hair in the pool was always just
Devin making fun of him being like dude
what do you come
see I wasn't equipped with any of that I
would see them and be like
[Music]
dude I was trying to come
way because it was he was the first one
so we were like you know we were all
jealous that he could come yeah that's
funny I didn't think about that Playbook
I was just kind of like
I just I turned it in that's been my
playbook since day one it's a sick once
I realized I wasn't good at basketball I
was like
basketball's so [ __ ] gay
I would like do layup lines at tryouts
just throw it against the backboard be
like this [ __ ] sucks dude
yeah
so the second I realized I'm not really
good at something I'm like dude anyone
who does that is [ __ ] gay for sure
oh my God you're such a sick movie
you're dancing with my [ __ ] homo I'm
gonna dance or sing
there's someone's like you're a good
singer I'm like
I wish we had a recording of an
Australian dude getting upset with farts
could you please stop
passing gas at my cubicle that's
actually a pretty good like any anybody
that gets mad about a fart is a [ __ ]
unless it's a chick
and it's like I there was one time at
football camp that's a huge excuse I
farted
and my roommate because you it was at
like a college dorm and my roommate who
had no idea who he was I farted like
very loudly it was an offensive lineman
Camp it was all big [ __ ] I
farted Extremely Loud and he was like we
don't do that here wow all right all
right guys I'm out I'm switching around
offensive lineman yeah exactly he's an
offended lineman wow
wow wow excuse me oh could you please
stop yeah I'm gonna go the FA Cup Final
I've Got My Ticket he's gonna hate this
because I've done nothing but talk so
even while I'm sat here talking to you
we've been very excited to get on most
of my brain at the minute is singing
Liverpool songs I can't set it off we're
trying to win you guys [ __ ] love
singing oh 100 the British all you guys
do is you get [ __ ] up and no sing no
singing in the NFL apart from the chief
and being borderline racist yeah
yeah like you guys love singing you guys
sing outside of football yeah just in
the bar everywhere on the way on the
coach down on the plane so me and Finn
went over to Spain this week because
look it is gay
with your boys is gay but I'm just
jealous I wish we sang dude anytime you
guys are I've been to a couple I've been
to a bunch of soccer games and every
time everyone's singing I'm like
this is so cool like I was going to
Tottenham they all started saying and I
was like this is incredible Oh see now I
really want to get you a ticket in our
end for the FA Cup Final I'm not singing
songs though what are they singing I
don't I can't understand they're not
like oh Oklahoma
if the Tottenham fans started singing
that I'd be like this is a little camp
but it's no matter what they're singing
It's oh come on Liverpool's sing like
ABBA songs with different words so it
probably is a little bit come from the
most most football songs are a parody
yeah of an original song so the big
Liverpool song at the minute uh the
newest one is uh how have we got here a
parody of The Beatles I feel fine so
Jurgen said to me you know we'll win the
Premier League you know he said so I'm
in love with him that is a big guy
and I hope man
[Music]